when you hear the name Kate Spade what
are the first things that come to mind
well for me with the browned it was
going back to the very beginning and
looking at like color this very
optimistic joyful women and very
spirited women and that was really one
of the starting points when I started
working with the brand how are you
paying homage to Kate Spade today okay
actually I feel all of the work that we
do that I do with the team is is a
legacy to her because it's still her
name but we were listening to a lot of
the tributes when after Kate's passing
and one of the phrases that really kept
resonating was that she left a little
bit of sparkle wherever she went and we
wanted to use that in a way to tribute
her today so there's an element of
sparkle throughout the collection
whether it's a little touch in the
makeup or there's a line in the middle
of the runway that's this beautiful pink
carpet that is a glitter line so that's
one of the ways we're attributing yeah
what are you most excited to see today
I'm really excited to see the reaction
because it's my first show but I'm
excited to be able to showcase all the
work that we've been doing over the past
six months and for people to see I'm
hoping of feel that it's a little bit
familiar but completely new at the same
time so it's changed about the brand
would you say in the last six months I
think that and so certain elements like
whether it's the brand's always stood
for color and have really bright fun
colors but looking at more unexpected
ways to do that whether it's mixing like
the chartreuse with the pale lilac and
then the print language really
developing a new fun print language with
a lot of unexpected details so for
example a floral print where there's a
little lip hidden in the center of the
floor you'll see in the show we have
some great boots as well so like a lilac
boot or a bright yellow boot so you guys
be doing more runway shows this is your
first
this is the first time I need to see how
it goes today but I'm really excited to
just see the models moving and I wanted
the setting because it's quite intimate
as well and so people can really get the
chance to see the clothes close up at
the same time and you're going with more
of the clover rather than the name cake
plate is there a reason behind them no
we're still standing for the name can't
spare but this is actually and it was a
pattern that was developed it's the
constructed speed that we developed into
a flower pattern so it's just another
element that we've been working with
with the brand because the speed the
speed still there but sometimes we're
making it more obvious like in a large
closure in a bag or more subtle hidden
in a pattern
[Music]
[Applause]